[Music]
man Morris is really pulling for a
coyote ugly rebou what do you make of it
it's almost been 20 years it's insane
yeah I'm down I can actually I can
actually do on the bar legally this time
so it's all good you would be down for
it you would be down to even Joe and I
let's do it let's write some new songs
were to be fun leann rimes ready for a
coyote ugly reboot it's been almost 18
years since the original came out the
singer turns 36 next month are you ready
for your birthday cuz that's coming up
yeah that is coming up yeah I'm gonna
hit that first yeah I know I am I can't
I didn't even need the thought about it
much actually does Eddy plan cute things
well we're actually gonna be in Paris
for his show he's doing some press over
there for his show we're taking the kids
I'm right before my birthday we were
gonna go somewhere we're there and then
now I'm kind of like I just want to come
back home bet he always plans out such a
good day yeah
he's a good happy that way 100% and I
love what you were saying about the boys
and how you travel with them do you have
baby fever yet um no not at the moment
between all of this I have going on a
Teddy show actually I get it every once
in a while I don't know and I'm trying
to figure out what it is that that stirs
it haven't figured that out yet cuz
everyone said I'll be like what is
making me want a baby like right now
like right now I haven't figure that all
yeah but it hasn't stuck maybe one day I
mean I love my stepkids and you know I
get plenty on my plate with them so I'm
cool at the moment et chatted with
Leanne at a Hallmark summer TCA bash to
her movie it's Christmas Eve will air
this holiday season are we gonna hear
you sing in this new movie yeah you
actually do I'm the movie has a lot of
music intertwine of course but I didn't
want to hit it right on the nose I wrote
three songs for it actually which I love
these songs it's not like you can
actually take them out of the movie and
they're like really really good songs
I'm proud of them so my character has a
love for music but she's not she's not
like a singer
you know necessarily so the way that I
the way that music it's been intertwined
in my character and involved in her life
and actually brought back into her life
is really beautiful
[Music]